lot thank you so much for being here
with me today of course so
exactly it's a big deal it is a big deal
so I want to start with you at the very
beginning tell me how you got your start
in music okay this is kind of funny so
follow me so my dad is like Street D
into cars um just a lot of people just
knows a lot of people um whatever so I'm
around this like Fast lifestyle and then
in school language JSU was always my
favorite subject mine too I
really smart girl um I I just loved word
play like metaphors SES um writing
essays and poems like that was just so
second nature for me so um I I had this
passion and then this lifestyle I'm
already growing up around it they kind
of just like like combin my two worlds
interesting oh that's really cool so
then how did you start breaking on to
the scene walk me through the stepy tuck
so in my
household if you say you want to do
something we doing it full-fledged like
it's not a hobby we we prepping for real
life like we taking it serious like a
career so when I told my dad that I
wanted to rap from that point forward um
I'm doing ciphers talent shows open mics
um posting like my my flyers around the
city on stop signs um we printed up my
mixtapes and we're passing them out at
festivals in Atlanta um selling them in
like the Walmart parking lot I'm getting
picked up from school doing my homework
in the studio Lobby and then going to
the booth like full-fledged this is your
career now wow yeah so I also want to
hear about your experience on the
reality show the rap game you know that
how did one what made you want to go on
that and take that Journey yeah um so
everything that I'm talking about as far
as like the cyers and the talent shows
and stuff that was like creating a buzz
where I'm from so then I had like pretty
crazy YouTube views um Twitter followers
I think Myspace was at the time too
Facebook friends whatever so the people
who were doing the rap game the
producers of the rap game found me
through social media but social media
wouldn't have been a thing if I wasn't
putting in that groundwork like right
hustling and networking so they found my
my social media and they was like boom
we want to put her on the rap game and
then that was like my first Launchpad
for my career and you ended up winning
and she turned down I know which is
amazing but then you turned down the
record contract yeah what was going
through your mind and what were you
thinking when that happened um it I
can't take all the credit it was
definitely a decision Guided by my
parents thank God I've had my parents um
in like the early stages of my career to
um help me make the best decisions but
it was more so just like you know this
is the first big step in my career I
don't want to rush my my process um I
was just so young um I was 16 when I did
the rap game so like signing a record
deal at the time sounded like huh you
know I wasn't ready for like the
commitment just yet and I knew I had a
lot of work um to still be putting in I
wanted to go into a situation where I
had leverage you know um with that show
it it was it was more so tv less like
music centered yeah I just wanted I when
it felt right I was going to be ready
Fair M so talk to me about when it
started to feel right when did you find
that leverage and how did that come
about so I wanted to like find myself as
a artist a little more um grow up as a
woman too um so I think you know just as
I grew up over the years I got my first
apartment had my first boyfriend and you
know just life things I had better music
um to to make and just life experiences
so I think after I did um [__] from the
south was like my first song that took
off um [__] from the south and just I
had been on some more video shoot sets
and um just networked a little more and
I was like okay I think I think I'm
reaching my capacity as an independent
artist I feel like I need I need some
departments working 24 hours around the
clock yeah when I'm not you know exactly
and this year you were nominated for
Best New Artist at the Grammys crazy
talk to me about one how you felt when
you first found out you were nominated
and then two that night walk me through
it okay this is so funny I was asleep
when I found out I was nominated I was
asleep um everybody was blowing up my
phone I think I had landed like early
like on a red eye flight early that
morning so or I was out late something
something happened that night before so
I was sleep and I hear my phone ding
ding
ding I'm like this better be important
every everybody blowing up my phone so I
finally reach over to look and I see a
whole bunch of like congratulations text
and then um my an anr Derek was calling
me at the same time so when um when I
answered I'm like he like niggaer you
got you got you got nominated for a
grand if you know Dar then you know but
um yeah and then from that point on I
was literally in and out of tears all
day wow in and out of tears all day it
that day was just so surreal like I
remember going to sleep like did that
really happen today
crazy and what was it like when you were
there on the day oh my gosh um I really
feel like our eyes was against me that
day it just it was it was so crazy I had
a bad um hair malfunction that day so I
was like super late I had to rush in
there they was literally taking down the
um the red carpet they was taking it
down like unbuilding it like the
construction workers have ladders out
and they're like no we're not taking
pictures I'm like please you don't know
what I've been through today I just want
to go in so I they let me get my
pictures I'm running in there and then
from that day well from that moment
forward it was like The Best Day Ever me
and broo my sister Brook we was sitting
at the table with Fat Joe DJ khi I met
Coco um I was like a table away from
Beyonce wow it was it was very
nerve-wracking but I was really I was
like just bring the drinks out let's
just let's just kick back and relax now
I had a long day what was your like I
I've made it now
moment o
I'm so hard on
myself I'm not going I'm not going to
act like I haven't had those moments but
I it's like I still need the reassurance
um definitely being nominated for a
Grammy was definitely one of them
um yeah it's like I I I in a weird way I
be feeling like I haven't yet really why
um I don't know I just feel like it's so
much that I want to do and I feel like
um I'm still on the up I don't think I'm
nowhere near my Peak um so I I think
there's there's a lot more for me to do
to feel like I made it I mean I bought
my mama car I bought my sister
car I I've definitely passed
out probably like six cars something
like that yeah so that that's where I
get my fulfillment from to just like
seeing other people happy but me
personally I always need like
reassurance like I need my friends from
high school to come around and they be
like Lista you doing it big you doing it
big and I be like I mean I guess I kind
of am yeah that's really cool what was
your first big purchase that you made
when you knew you my first big
purchase my first first first
one do not do this actually we're going
to speak on this I bought a Bentley
truck and that [__] was sitting in my
driveway for about a good year year did
not move like tires flat don't buy a car
don't buy a car not worth it no it's not
worth it like you're going to think it's
old and like a year and you're just gon
to want something else it's like yeah
don't even buy so you mentioned this
earlier you said you know social media
really helped you blow up but a lot of
your songs go viral on Tik Tok on social
media do you contribute that with the
the rise of your career and Rise your
music I would say yes as far as like the
most recent years but I think the
difference between me and a lot of
younger artists right now is I caught
the tail end of a
generation before social media like
strong present social media like I had
my MySpace um and like my Facebook and
I'm promoting that and like my YouTube
channel but it wasn't like a launch pad
so to say it was more so like oh that's
cute it wasn't such a prominent thing
yet like I remember physically passing
out CDs and like people putting their
CDs in my car like oh yeah she hard she
hard like you know so I think um I have
a I have a different type of respect um
and passion for what I do too because I
caught the tail end of like very two
very different times right but it's the
recent years for sure social media all
day Tik Tok everything is gets all the
credit for sure what is the most
challenging part of navigating the music
industry for
you the most challenging
part trusting in my good there's a lot
of times where it's like you know they
say it takes a village and it takes a
team and I'm such a firm believer in
that but you can also lose yourself in
other people's opinions and having too
many cooks in the kitchen so I think one
of the hardest things I had to learn is
like balance between trusting myself and
taking outside opinion so that I can
grow but at the end of the day you know
yourself and your vision and what you
want to um be perceived how you want to
be perceived what would you say are some
of the difficulties of managing you know
yourself as a brand I manage myself
currently so that's a really funny
question um the hardest
part um I you know everything is
difficult waking up early
difficult um scheduling things making
sure you know you're allotting self-care
self time um me time because you can
easily crash out with um with this
industry and just the amount of time it
takes like a lot of people have work a 9
to5 but this is like a 12 to 12 yeah sun
up to sun down you cannot clock out um
so I think everything about it is
difficult and and off camera that's why
I told you like I really love what I do
this is so strenuous that I would would
have been quit if I did not genuinely
enjoy it it's it's so strangest and so
demanding of your time and energy it's
like I can't even choose the hardest
thing I'm sure yeah do you do you ever
want to you know expand outside of music
do you have any other business
aspirations you're dying a Pursuit yes I
love music don't get me wrong but I
really feel like um it's a it's a
Launchpad I feel like that's that's how
I got my foot in the door but um it's
get older I I really feel my
businesswoman since it's te okay I I
love Riri and um everything like Riri
cut the check for me so I know she
getting checks on checks on checks you
know and she just used I feel like she
used her music as a way to get in the
door and just build gener generational
wealth from there with her um her other
passions like Beauty and clothing and I
definitely see that for myself for sure
are you passionate about those same
spaces or is there something else that
you're really into you know I'm I'm like
Loki a a very girly girl so definitely
like Beauty I do my own makeup a lot so
definitely like Beauty um clothing I I
love clothes um I like acting I did my
first acting gig this year and I loved
it so maybe like something with acting
um I really love writing so maybe maybe
a book in the future or something like
that and it's funny you say that cuz
literally my next question was going to
be about you Premier on grownish earlier
this year which is which is amazing do
you see yourself you know switching into
the acting Hollywood side of things in
the future I do okay I do um I like I
like to have um I like the freedom that
comes with acting at least shout out to
the the team at gronish they they
definitely made my first acting
experience very comfortable it seems
like oh I can pretty much just improvise
and kind of like be myself like stick to
the script but with a little twist and I
like that it's kind of similar to like
the music world I feel like for the most
part we get to just be ourselves and I
like that in the acting world it's like
yeah I have this script but I can kind
of put my own twist on this character
and like embody the character how I
would so I like the freedom of acting
for sure going back to business is there
one business rule that you always
operate by no matter what I have a few
so so anytime I get booked for anything
or um any money that comes in I have to
profit at least
50% definitely taking half of that home
this you have a lot of overhead at least
for a woman doing this lots of overhead
dancers makeup hair so expensive so
definitely um we we're we're going to
get a number from me every time I'm
coming home with this um about 50% I'm
not gonna say like it could be more it
could be less but like yeah um also put
them taxes aside put them taxes aside
cuz you going to get across the face
like me and you going be like what
happened where did the money go oh no
yeah so definitely um putting them taxes
aside throughout the year and um setting
setting a standard for what you want to
come home with cuz you will see that
overhead eat it up like or you will know
like you'll go to the event thinking oh
I'm coming home with such and such we
going to the club afterwards and then
you look up you like H how did I get
booked for this and come home with this
know definitely um trial and error to
learn those type of things how do you
manage that like you know just flipping
into that business side of the brain cuz
I know you're a creative yeah um I
really wear so many hats that it's it's
just another one of the hats it's like
at this point it's just another one of
the hats um I try to stick to to my
expertise which is creative but um I'm
going to always have my my nose in in
the business cuz at the end of the day
that that is the goal you know music
don't last forever not going to be this
young and fine forever you
know speaking of that so how do you
maintain being yourself you know the one
offstage and also dealing with you know
the public image of you I think it's
easier for me to deal with it because
it's it's me like I know Alysa I think
it's harder for other people to
understand because it's like Lotto is
this personality Lotto is an Entertainer
Alyssa is who I am so I wake up and I'm
Alyssa and I think like when people meet
Alyssa like lot off stage they're like
oh she's so softspoken or she's so quiet
or she's shy whatever and for me it's
like oh like I just know how to turn on
the switch because they are two separate
people I think it's harder for other
people to understand that though going
along with that you know how do you
handle the stress of constantly you know
marketing yourself you're you're kind of
your own
product my mind is working around the
clock um when it comes to like me as a
product because at the end of the day we
are products as artists we are products
um I'm my mind is constantly running
like I have a Notes app in my phone and
it'll say like PR ideas next video ideas
um next photo shoot concept ideas like
constantly running um I just keep like
my notepad I I jot stuff down um I watch
documentaries I scroll on
Pinterest um even even small things like
watching a movie can like spark interest
or spark inspiration um for like a next
marketing idea but it it definitely
doesn't stop like constantly thinking of
new ways to Market myself and just build
build it bigger than ever for sure who
is your dream collaborator both in the
business world and in the music world
business Riri Riri Riri I I just feel
like she touched Our Generation in in a
whole different way like I feel like
women like me who might have like a
little motion little motion going on you
know she showed us that it's possible
for us to take it to a whole different
level um so definitely reread really
music and business what's up R call me
girl that's that's I would I would stick
around for for sure for sure I just feel
like I did a song with Mariah Carey I
did a song with Christina agila it's
like I did song with Lil Wayne it's it's
so Limitless like I don't even I don't
know it's I Feel Like Anything Can
Happen like speaking of that what's next
for you like what are you most excited
for in 2024 2024 hopefully I'm launching
my first business venture in 2024
definitely been working on that can you
share it or is it still still very
secret it's one of the things I me
mentioned okay one of things I mentioned
so hopefully fingers crossed on that um
my sister has a business she just opened
up her first business so she has a
cosmetic line Beauty by Brooklyn I help
her behind the scenes with that um
pretty much like the investor and she
makes everything happen so um building
that bigger than ever um hopefully more
acting gigs definitely want to do some
more acting gigs and I'm excited to
see how me managing my myself and I also
have a team too but like for the most
part I'm managing myself um where that
takes me like me having two hands on the
steering wheel because I started so
young it's like I'm not used to having
to say so and just being such
a decision maker in my in my career it's
it's been fun to like see my Visions
come to life um as a kid you know and
especially coming from a TV show I feel
like there's always been a lot of cooks
in the kitchen I'm the cook in the
kitchen so 2024 should be very inspiring
and motivating for me for a listen and I
hear you have a new album coming out I
do tell me about that super excited
about my next um my next wave of Music
I've been like very vulnerable lately so
um I just have a story to tell that I
want to get more in in depth on like I
think people see me grow up as a kid but
they don't really have the story down
packed how I want them to or just
understand my story I want them to so
this music will be definitely different
than what you've heard that's awesome
and I'll end this because I think this
is a great way to go from here what
would you like your legacy to
be I think about that all the time I'm a
Capricorn so I'm like uh I think so far
ahead like if you ask me I feel like I
got to be prepared to fall off tomorrow
you never know like to the extreme but
um I want my legacy to
be something along the lines of
just a girl from a small town Clan
County who really just knew what she
wanted at a young age and made it happen
um never gave up never took no for an
answer I really just worked long long
and hard um for what I wanted and it was
a lot of blood is SL was a lot of Blood
Sweat and Tears um Maybe not maybe not
Blood Sweat and Tears for sure
oh well thank you so much for being here
with me I really appreciate it good luck
than you thank you so
much